Okay.
So there has been this explosion of controversy
from Donald Trump calling the mostly black
city of Baltimore, a rodent infested mess.
Uh, that was somewhere in those 30 or so tweets
that Donald Trump sent.
Um, the, uh, Baltimore, the population of
Baltimore is two thirds black is 62% black,
30% white.
He's also talked about Elijah Cummings who
is the black congressman from Maryland.
So let's look specifically now at the Baltimore
related tweets.
Once again, uh, Trump tweeting congressman
Elijah Cummings has been a brutal bully shouting
and screaming at the great men and women of
Border Patrol about conditions at the southern
border when actually his Baltimore district
is far worse and more dangerous.
His district is considered worst in the USA
as proven last week during a congressional
tour.
The border is clean, efficient, and well run,
just very crowded.
Cummings district is a disgusting rat and
wrote an infested mess.
If he spent more time in Baltimore, maybe
he could help clean up this very dangerous
and filthy place.
So of course this is being called racist by
lots of people because it is hugely racially
tanged and it's tanged with some of the same
language that white nationalists use and that
antisemites and Nazis historically used about
Jews.
Is it demonstrably actually racist?
I mean, yeah, it probably is, but I'm going
to make the case to you today that it actually
doesn't matter at this point.
Debating whether this is racist is a loser's
game in this particular case, and I think
the left needs to understand this going forward.
Republicans immediately after Donald Trump
was accused of being racist for criticizing
Baltimore in this way, Republicans immediately
pointed to Bernie Sanders prior comments that
Baltimore is a third world country and a disgrace.
Now, the context was totally different, but
it immediately muddies the water.
Did Bernie mean that it's a third world country
because there's black people?
So yes, this infested stuff is the same language
that goes back to Nazi terminology about Jews,
about Jews as an infestation like roaches
or vermin that needs to be exterminated.
It's the same language.
There is no doubt about it.
And of course, immediately the conversation
becomes about, well, Nancy Pelosi says it
is racist.
And Trump's talking not about Baltimore, uh,
itself.
Uh, or, or Elijah Cummings.
He's talking about the circumstances in Baltimore
and even Bernie has agreed, he's literally
talking about rats.
He's not saying black people or as he's saying,
there is a big rat problem in Baltimore and
you are actually racist because you see Trump's
comments as racist.
You're the problem, not us.
I do not think that having another public
adjudication of if or how racist Trump's comments
are is going to help our movement remove Donald
Trump.
Now there will be some of the audience who
disagree with me and they will say, we've
got to be calling this out.
I want to be really clear here.
I'm not saying Trump's comments aren't racist.
They are hugely racially tanged the languages
of language that we've seen among racist for
a very, very long time.
I'm not saying Trump doesn't have a lot of
racist supporters.
He obviously does.
What I'm thinking out loud about here is that
I don't see the path between another five
days back and forth about who thinks Trump's
comment was racist and who doesn't.
I don't see that as being useful to the goal
of removing Donald Trump in 2020 and blinging
bringing some semblance of sanity back to
the United States because remember I told
you weeks ago, this is now a strategy.
Lots of people are supporting Trump because
of comments like this.
This is who they increasingly are publicly.
Trump has emboldened them to publicly say
they support this language.
It's not a liability for Trump's reelection
for him to use this language.
If Trump's public racism isn't a liability,
then I don't know what we gain by having these
incidents.
Occupy five days in the media, have a debate
over how racist was it at the exclusion of
reporting about all of the terrible things
that Donald Trump and his administration are
actually doing.
I believe we are fomenting a pointless cycle,
not one that isn't based on fact.
Okay?
I'm not defending the comments.
For example, though, yesterday morning, Trump's
chief of staff, Mick Mulvaney, was on TV defending
Donald Trump's use of the word infested when
there are many more important things that
Mick Mulvaney should be confronted about.
So this is now a secondary news cycle to take
attention away from the immediate crises that
are going on.
The focus should be, it's beneath the office
of the president to insult cities and to insult
members of Congress and to talk in this way
period.
Meanwhile, the border is a human rights fiasco.
Trump has destroyed alliances all over the
world.
The White House is now a laughing stock under
Trump.
We're Americans.
We don't want to be a laughingstock around
the world and Trump has failed to deliver.
Basically every campaign promise his supporters
cannot be reasoned with and therefore a five
day debate over who thinks the comments were
racist, how racist was it?
What stupid ways can Trump is fined to defend
Trump is not going to help us win in 2020
okay.
The constant disarray and reaction to the
content of Trump's tweets lets him control
the story and the narrative.
There is a narrative about the tweets that
we need to talk about.
It's that they are part of the propaganda
model that allows Donald Trump to control
the discussion.
That should be our analysis and I'll be talking
about that later on today.
If you disagree with my perspective on this,
let me know.
I'm on Twitter at the pacman and the show
is on Twitter at David Patton show,